going back to your own experience where
you were slated to write this script
what were some of the excuses that you
use or some of the busy work that you
took hold up to keep you away from
actually finishing it well that you see
others doing as an excuse because
they're scared or they don't really want
to do it whatever the reason is I I
didn't really know that I wasn't
passionate about it not it see III I had
the dream but I didn't know that the
day-to-day process would be so
unrewarding for me that was what I
really finally realized is you know I
don't really want to do this everyday it
doesn't feel good it doesn't feel right
it doesn't feel it doesn't give me any
pleasure it's not my passion so I had to
realize that I just had a writer tell me
that the other day a beginner who's been
got a lot of success he won a contest a
year or so ago and he has told me a
month ago sitting up here I just I don't
want to do this I really don't I thought
I did but I don't
so sometimes it's really not our dream
and we need to realize that but what I
often see people do is not actually
write this is the most common thing I
see they don't actually produce on the
page every day they say they do they go
to classes they'll go to seminars but
it's almost like porno for them they'd
rather watch it than do it if you don't
write every day if you don't sit down
for whatever you decide an hour two
hours three hours it's hard to write
creatively more than three hours by the
way but some people do it but if you
don't actually put words on the page
every day then you can't say I'm a
writer
you're never gonna succeed that way and
that's what I see more than anything
else I'll get another book on how to do
it I'll go to another class on how to do
it but will I actually sit down and
write every day no I don't feel like it
today I just I'm not I'm not inspired
today the muse isn't hitting me that's
what I see over and over again that
people do to fail that's a big one
you